[Music]
welcome back to dirty RT chapter 19 Oh
Joey we're getting there 220 almost
there almost there legal that's right
it's dirty RT unfortunately Jake is out
this week on vacation but fortunately
Joey is here once again to substitute
hello for that man in this episode we
decided to hit and robbed five general
stores at least there are eight total
but the three that you can't do you need
to have beat in the game so we're just
gonna do the five meaning we're gonna
start if you want to let go of all of
your mat we've Joe and I have spent days
devising this plan Dave a serie is a
series of waypoints we have known as it
makes sense it's it's one way point but
we're gonna string along all these
general stores so we can end inside the
neat but we are starting to start we're
gonna start in strawberry okay start
strawberry we're gonna head north east a
little bit to wallace station they have
a nice general store here a little
marker here
mmm-hmm and then keep heading a little
more east to good ol valentine stomping
grounds and then all the way down here
over the roads that's right and then
finally end it in good ol son Danny
that's right there yeah yeah the
Valentine two roads track will be a
lengthy one but we here's the thing is
that it's so easy to get sidetracked and
dirty already episodes so we have to be
diligent we have to be constructive and
we have to be focused but something that
I don't think we've done any of those
things at one point in time yeah it's a
it's a challenge in itself so let's hit
up let's hit this first door so it
should be easy I think yeah
so I don't think we necessarily need to
kill the store clerk let's interrogate
them first no there's a lot of people
outside a lot of activity here yeah
might just be the last time you see us
well we should also stock up on
provisions of course that's fair in this
safe in this dirty already time line
we're losing a lot of money
I don't know if you noticed we're we're
down to not 9,000 ish dollars yeah I was
about to say also this is a earlier
timeline just based off the coat and
beard length I think that's our job
where's my lasso can they not bring it
out yet there we go now
I don't think you can lasso him and it's
no good let here oh my god
- hell yeah all can we bring this to our
clerk with us oh he's coming with us
sick so far this is pretty successful
let's just hope that no one is outside
to see us walk out with this guy gone oh
my god
oh no we're on our way it's a rob one of
the things I remember from last time I
was on here people the one one of the
reasons why people kind of miss Jake oh
yeah was because I didn't have the dirty
arty voice oh the voice Jake does the
voice the best I am NOT as but you're
you're good enough you can so I'll have
to keep at it no the one question I
asked is if you could teach me a
everyone else and I think well it's kind
of the perfect time since I'm I kinda
have a sore throat right now so am i
perfect well it's it's a low tone you
definitely need a little bit of rasp and
a little bit of sass and a lot of
mumbling so a lot of dirty already
doesn't really speak coherently I think
you need this horse we lost them I think
this one was just Tennessee Walker might
want to take that saddle yeah all my
cell right
oh yeah anyway the voice the voice oh
yeah yeah oh yeah give it a shot take a
whirl so just you got to be a low low
low
oh no rat you have a real rat
[Laughter]
make that McPeak dog damn it that's
pretty good that's it well here we are
practicing lines a sweet here it's on
our way with our Sam else is he gonna do
well he's he has all this free time
family lore just watch but Hardy voice
hi there there horse we have it yeah
horse - horse to get horse this is my
shadow Oh horse that horse
[Music]
good girl hahaha
trains here I can't miss it payment sir
no concern me my dear you you and feud
like a fly you infuse with kick me out
messing out my wardrobe you put that gun
away all your money open that thing
don't hurt me I'll I'll cooperate I
worked hard for every bill in corn
you're taking we never thought to hear
his full story last time party hurry up
go move it
[Music]
see two stores down a little smoke break
mm-hmm
start a wildfire cape it home sweet home
I'm back we'll get to Robin first I
don't think we've seen the show now
we've only seen the vaudeville one I
don't we've seen this one apparently
there's nothing like it
[Music]
Molotov cocktail oh you can do that
maybe I have some dynamite arrows Oh
perfect you didn't really didn't even do
anything
I'd sky all look down shut your mouth am
I gonna get away with this
clean come on
I can't pick him up
all right let's go horsey with us no way
I forgot to set fire to the the show Oh
dry I do a drive-by that one got him
okay now I'm nice and muddy yeah you are
what are we feeling feeling kind of
adventurous today okay yeah on the road
again gonna rob every general store
again arty maybe gross vile discussing
money 90% of the time but he takes pride
in what he wears
damn straight ooh you got a top hat was
that a worn stovetop
yeah just shoot off his head just want
the Hat
looking good nice
no they won't recognize me my alias has
changed Hey
my character is totally different your
rides away maybe maybe what he was
trying to say was like eat my dust now
it's his fault he from that corner Luba
- so he did not have a blinker on what
it's like the videos of two babies
talking to each other it's like they're
having their own conversations yeah it
appears they're having like a dialogue I
mean Artie's just always in his own
world
ooh look where we are Oh roads on the
roads again
[Music]
oh that's a llama oh sorry Oh ain't this
just a cute little house here cabin hey
hey there mister sorry I don't know so
the Hat that I was thinking of is over
here like a scarecrow hat yeah and it
looks it looks pretty good Oh knack
knack nice sick horse perfect and clean
well not clean but that's pretty clean
shameless get away that's what it's for
that's for one level Oh Hasaan delay
alright let's go get that hat though you
can end in style oh hello there once
again they have no idea who I am now a
whole different person one last stop
it's the arty roadtrip deeper deeper
yeah
this final general store might be a bit
trickier than I expected they see me
answer question fair yep see ya
helping those here on the mini-map I'll
take it
like to think this is when God it's like
no dirty idea I need you back we are
[Laughter]
let's have some printer be here looks
good God make self look a little uh are
you ready for this final act yeah I like
a shower listen just just take what you
want and go how dare you who saw that
a little bird nobody oh there's one guy
outside
you gotta get you gotta get out of here
Browntown oh my god that's we make our
we should skip my boat away we go
Oh what okay it's not gonna work Oh
perfect
this is how we make our get I told you I
was feeling dangerous into the mist he
just robbed five stores Oh after all
that hard work it's uh be nice to spend
some time to ourselves on a little
island you're gonna perylene combat over
there the island over there I mean yes
and dirty already lived the rest of his
days in peace not as always it's now
time for show us you're already where
you guys show us on Twitter your dirty
arty submissions that you've created the
dirtiest Artie's you can come up with
yes you want to see them all we do we
always want to see them so please send
them our way and taking a look at ban a
tab one he said he made a Twitter
account just to share this photo not
really a great arty to show but it I
dropped a dead body and from three
lawmen and they still there's looking at
it that's pretty awesome
I've never seen a dead body before in
their lives we probably have so much
paperwork to do up next this I know this
is so impressive I cannot I cannot
believe how awesome this is this is like
a freakin truly impressive piece of art
right here this is by bluej art dirty
already the drunken terror of the West
everything about this is just he's got
the donkey's got he's got the donkey's
expression the exhaustion of the donkey
is is awesome just finished a can of
beans as dirty beans on it oh oh good
really good I love it thank you so much
Jay Lane they even gave the donkey the
breeded tail yeah it's so good that's so
good thank you thank you so much this is
Dale Pendergast who says the twists on
the cover picture of Red Dead Redemption
to just show him the can of beans it's
like a threat range oh my god I just I
got one glance I I thought you know what
it's hard for joining it in there I'm
torn here because I want to kind of
break it down because I couldn't break
it down at first glance so I guess the
first thing I see there is is Dutch
saying listen to my plan and I think
everyone else is ignoring him well Artie
was going off on his bean trail right
there right there is
oh Jesus Christ oh god no Jesus Christ
oh thank you Tony Peters up next is Cody
Burchfield said I took a nap while my
girlfriend played woke up and found this
that's fair is worth capturing loved it
thank you so much
Mesa Fenner I buy 1 Omega faucet with
the pop no pop vinyls sorry final thank
you I was confused I thought they were
called something else but no I was wrong
and they are called poop oh we should so
cuz you know how how many pop vinyls
they make like of all sorts of different
characters like like spin-offs and like
different versions of all of them mm-hmm
I'm just gonna talk to funk oh yeah good
dirty Artie in there and if they won't
add the blood we will Mike McDonald hell
yeah I don't even know I don't know
where this is but apparently he found
like a taxidermy I was like a little
diorama diorama yeah like and the bottom
the bottom photo there is magnificent
kind of like the equivalent of dogs
playing poker I feel like so good is
that home with all the skunk's I think
that's it the top one there looks like
it's raccoons fighting the rabbits like
this the great Civil War that's so
awesome
I do not know Thank You Harvey pill so
his managed to get a shot that made it
look like Artie had a cigarette in his
mouth pretty good I missed those ohm
where they called the the killcam yeah
killcams I think we haven't turned off
maybe that's possible we should probably
yeah because there's some some of the
really good ones that people have sent
in were like holding the can of beans
and all that I want Peyton Lowrey yeah
that's some pretty awesome artwork right
there
this is peas by the way not beans I can
right put the green oh you're right or
or he's just got puke all over him
either way and the honors symbol oh
that's what that is
of course over his missing or sorry
that's that's a sensor mark yeah that's
so awesome so good thank you so much
rage here it says before and after the
taste of beans so he must have captured
it twice yeah
cleanly shaven and yeah covered in dirt
and looking like crap and racism very
frightening and also by rage is you know
and very much the same vein of dirty
already he got a little creative with
dead bodies so hey that's Pigman there
pig on the bottom and then J&R for Joey
and myself for Jake it Rob and Jake
Jesus Joey and Jake yeah you're right
for both for sure well so how do these
guys get so many I've seen a lot of
photos with just a pile of bodies all
over the place I want to know where to
get them all yeah that's not easy to do
I feel like most people go to Van Horn
because there's no there's no law there
that's a good point well we'll go there
next time yeah definitely and that's it
that's last one oh thank you guys so
much thank you Joey for subbing in for
Jake yeah and yes show us your artis
next week and we'll see you all next
week for chapter 20 big to zero thank
you guys
[Music]